Think there's two times the door to the subconscious mind opens up when we wake up in the morning
And we go to bed at night and it's simple brain chemistry and simple physiology
We have a circadian rhythm soon as there's light
Our body has been pretty much programmed that we begin to release serotonin different chemicals that kind of wake us up
So our brain waves go from Delta to theta to alpha to beta and you kind of slide up this way
And then you're back to conscious awareness local in space and time when you go to bed at night
You go from beta to alpha to theta to Delta and you slide down now if you're stressed you can't stop thinking you stay in beta
You're thinking actually is arousing the body because you're thinking about your problems
You can't slide down those two points in the day when we wake up in the morning
Go to bed at night when we're in when alpha or our analytical facilities are suppressed or in theta
We're in a hypnotic state and the door between the conscious mind and the subconscious mind is wide open
What separates the conscious mind from the subconscious mind is the analytical mind?
So as you suppress analytical facilities, you can program anybody to do anything
Hey, it's Evan Carmichael and I make these videos because I need it
I need it for me because I don't wake up every day and say yes, let's go conquer the world
No
I wake up and and I need that external motivation to match my internal motivation when I see somebody who's doing
Amazing things it makes me just want to play a bigger game
And so I hope that today's video makes you want to play a bigger game too because your message matters and let's get it
So today let's open the door to our subconscious minds with dr. Joe Dispenza. Enjoy
What really happens for most people before they even reach for their cell phone and by the way the statistics are
86% of the people in the Western world
First thing first thing they do is they reach for the cell phone and they connect to everything that's known
And why is that a problem?
well, I
Would never tell people how to think but I would give them information to cause them to think so the device is
Reminding them of
Things that are known and every person every object everything every place is mapped
neurologically in our brain because we've experienced it and then we have an emotion associated with our coworker with our boss with our ex with
Our whoever and so the moment we start responding
Now we start feeling the same way
so now the
Environment is actually controlling the person's feelings and thoughts
yeah, and anything that controls the way we feel in the way we think we're victims to
So something's programming us to think and feel a certain way
There's nothing wrong with that you can you should check your tax but and do whatever you need to do
But the first thing in the morning if the door between the conscious mind the subconscious mind is open
Why don't we program a new behavior?
Why don't we rehearse a different way of being with our children with our spouse?
When our zoom meetings when we're alone when we're in traffic, is there a better way to evolve our experience?
So if you're truly in the game of evolution
You're truly in the game like one lifetime one day. What am I working on today?
Can I respond a different way to this person? Can I think this way instead of that way?
Let me be conscious of my unconscious thoughts
Let me not be in a habit. Let me stay away from certain emotions
Let me practice feeling these emotions. See if I can maintain it now you're in the game
You're out of the bleachers and you're on the playing field. So
It actually happens even before the cell phone
Because what most people do is they wake up and the first thing they do is the brain is a record of the past
They think other problems
And those problems are just memories that are etched in the brain that are connected to certain people and objects at certain times and places
The moment they think of their problems are thinking in the past
Then when they think about their problems and they feel unhappy now their bodies in the past and if you believe that your thoughts have
Something to do with your destiny. Yeah Wow
and then the emotion that's
associated there is now the bodies in the past because thoughts of the language of the brain feelings of the language of the body and
How we think and how we feel creates our state of being now, here's the problem if you can't think
greater than how you feel
And you believe that your thoughts have something to do with your destiny and you understand that feelings and emotions are record of the past
Then you're thinking in the past and your life
Will stay the same rule number two is reframe your reality being victimized by a circumstance in your life
Literally means that that that event that circumstance that person that condition is actually causing you
to feel
emotionally and
Think in terms of memories equal to that circumstance and that circumstances actually changes your state of being
So you're thinking the same way and you're feeling the same way in response to the environment is the same
We can guarantee that your life is going to stay the same because you're the same. Yes that person. Why are you unhappy?
Why are you frustrated? Why are you sad?
They'll say the this condition this is this person is actually making me feel and think this way
Well anything that makes us feel and think a certain way that we don't think we have any control over
For the most part we're victims
So we're as a species become victimized by the conditions in our life
And it's the environment then that is controlling the way we feel in the way we think
So the idea is if you can change the way you think and change the way you feel
could you begin to produce outcomes or
Effects in your life that cause you to believe that you're the creator of your life
Instead of the victim of your life
Which means then you would have to think greater than that
circumstance and you would have to feel differently in the presence of that circumstance and if you truly could and
begin to
Create an outcome the synchronicity of the serendipity of the coincidence that happens in your life
You're gonna pay attention to what you did and you're gonna realize that on some level you had a hand in that
You know that you are a participant in that our interest is to teach people how to reverse that process
Every person every circumstance every condition every place every object that you own is mapped neurologically in your brain
So your brain is a record of the past. It's it's an artifact the repository of everything
You've learned intellectually or experience and products of experience are called emotions the memories that we have in our life produces
familiar emotions or our response to anybody that we know in our life
there's a neurological network for your boss for your co-worker for your ex and for most people they're
their interaction in the environment is causing their
Environment to control their thinking or their personal reality is controlling their personality
So our interest to see is that well if your personality is made of how you think
How you act and how you feel is it possible if I begin to?
Change the way I think change the way I act and change the way life
I feel
should my life change because I'm changing and so the interest for us then is to be able to meet the
challenges and conditions in our life from a greater level of consciousness and and not be victimized by those circumstances, but to take time and
And to review how you're gonna think how you're gonna act and how you're gonna feel that's meditation and
Review how you're not gonna think, you know how you're not gonna act and how you're not gonna feel
It just turns out that tends to be 95% of who we are as those unconscious programs
So it's so much easier to forget and then to remember because it's the majority of who we are
You know after a certain point in our life. So changing that process the overcoming process of
That same self
somehow begins to produce effects in people's lives and that's that's kind of the exciting part about
Being a creator of your life also to make sure you're actually taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet just for this video
The worksheet will highlight all the lessons learned in this video as well as pull out our three
Favorite learnings and quotes that will inspire you to actually do something
the worksheet will also give you space to write down what your key takeaways are and your specific plan of
Action to make sure you're getting results if you want the worksheet designed specifically for this video. Absolutely for free
There's a link in the description below go click on it and start building the momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there. Well number three is reinvent yourself
I think the greatest relationship that you could ever have is with yourself
and taking time to be in the presence of yourself and ask yourself important questions like are you happy who am I and
Instead of getting up and getting on your cell phone and getting distracted
Sit with your triple filtered water or a glass of wine or whatever you're into JJ sit down and answer the question without being distracted
the contemplation process is the building process neurologically and
For me I was I was just a guy. I'm a guy who loves God. I'm a guy who loves the divine
I'm the guy who loves mystery. I'm the guy who just never stops dovetailing information
I mean, that's just me and I never really planned on doing any of this
I mean my theory is on life is make it up as you go along and take the value and run and and
What the bleep became a sensation and and all of a sudden I went from a normal guy to being a rock star
And I was traveling around the world and doing conferences all over the place and I reached this point where I realized that I wasn't
live in the work
And that really bothered me I was disturbed by that
I was really uncomfortable and when you get uncomfortable and nothing's making that discomfort go away. It's time to evolve
it's time to make a different choice and I
Clearly heard in my head during one meditation stop making the same choices and pause I
Didn't know what that meant
Except that I knew that I was relying on all of this external stimulation to build an identity that I really wasn't
And then I had to show up for people and look a certain way and act a certain way and that wasn't me
And it got disturbing for me and I had this gap between the way I appeared in the way
I really was and I didn't make time for myself and make time to be the example
I mean my motive is always be the example of everything that I teach if I'm not I'm not I shouldn't be up here
I shouldn't be leading in my clinic if I if I don't live those principles myself if I don't live my life that way and
and so
You know and at the height of
My popularity I disappeared I canceled all my
That's my friends thought I was on crack or something
I thought I lost my mind because you know what they were saying you could make so much money
And I said, I don't really I know how to make money. I really don't care about money
I really don't care about how happy I'm gonna be with myself
and I broke from the world for six months and retreated and
I really decided that if I presented myself back to the world that I wasn't gonna be seduced by it in the same way
That I really wanted to be the example of everything that I taught and I wanted to lead events in a way that
Empowered people I never wanted it to be about me
I want it to be about you rule number four is embrace change
the concept of transformation is a really important message and and we use meditation as
The mechanism because I want people to become so familiar with their old personality self that they don't default
Anymore and keep reaffirming that new person to get it's so much easier to forget that vision then to remember it
Constantly remind yourself reproduce the same level of mine
You got a constantly emotionally embrace it keep
Conditioning the body the thought and the feeling the image and the emotion the stimulus and response
You're conditioning your body into the future instead of waking up every morning and remembering your problems and those problems are associated with people
And object of things at certain times and places and if one of those problems as an emotion associated with so people are
Remembering their past and they're feeling the emotions. They're firing and wiring the same circuits and feeling the same motion
They're conditioning their body into the past and that's why change is so hard
Because the moment you step out from doing the same thing and making a different choice
There's going to be some discomfort because the body subconsciously has been programmed emotionally into the past
So the moment you make a different choice
You're stepping out of the known into the unknown the body starts influencing the mind to return back to the familiar place
That's why people have difficulty changing and yet if meditation is the model
To become so familiar with your old self and so familiar with your new self. How many times do we have to forget?
Until we stop forgetting and start remembering that's the moment called change. Okay, give people the tools and
Let them practice and they'll actually start enjoying it. Okay, but if
You're not being defined by a vision of the future
I assert you're left with the memories of the past and you'll be predictable in your life
So you wake up in the morning you see your co-worker you see your husband you see you're on a zoom call
You're picking up your cell phone
for most people it's the
Environment that's actually causing them to think and feel equal to everything that they know
So it's not their personality that's creating their personal reality. It's their personal reality. That's reaffirming their personality. It's their environment
That's controlling the way they feel in the way they think why because every person
Your husband your co-workers your your employees
Your dog your cell phone every one of those things you have a neurological network
That you've actually created because you've experienced them and because you've experienced and you have an emotion associated with them
So if we're not being defined by a vision of the future
When we see the same people we go to the same places and we do the exact same thing at the exact same time
The environment is controlling the way we feel and the way we think but if how we think and how we feel
Actually creates our life as long as we're thinking equal to everything that we know everything stays the same because nothing
Changes in our life until we change. Okay, so the conditioning process the thought and the feeling the memory and the emotion
You're thinking in the past when you remember your problems you feel the emotion associated with it
You're conditioning your body to become the mind of that emotion and it's so objective
It's believing it's living the same past experience 24 hours a day seven days a week
365 days a year and now you're headed a very specific jet genetic outcome
Okay, you get up you get up in the morning you do the same thing
You know as you did yesterday you go through this whole routine and you keep doing that your body's on autopilot now
And a habit is a redundant set of automatic
Unconscious thoughts behaviors and emotions that's acquired through repetition
Habit is when you've done something so many times the body actually knows not to do it better than your conscious mind. That means
Your body is the mind
It's dragging you into that predictable future based on what you did in the past and you lost your free will
To a set of programs and rule number five the last one before some very special bonus clips is don't live in survival mode
Now what's your environment made of objects things places bodies people, right? So it's very material
Okay
So now right the arousal causes us to pay more attention to the outer world and less attention to our inner world and those rush
Of chemicals causes us to become very preoccupied
With trying to make that feeling of survival and stress go away. So time becomes very relevant as well
So now your body is where you put your attention
Your environment is where you put your attention and your attention is on time
Well, it turns out to change is actually to be greater than your body to be greater than your environment and be greater than time
So if people are spending the majority of their life with the emergency system switched on
It's not a time to create. It's not a time to learn. It's not a time to go within
It's not a time to meditate it goes against the survival gene that says you will be prey
It's not a time to open your heart. It's not a time to commune. It's not even a time to eat
Yeah, so people spend the majority of their time
shutting
Let me say it another way
so then so then when a person is living in survival and they're trying to control and predict and
Change everything that's going on in their life
every person that they know every object or thing that they own every place that they know or have lived or go to
And everything they've experienced in their past. They're gonna try to predict in their future
so now the arousal of stress hormones causes the brain to fire out of order because
Every person every object everything has a different neurological network in the brain
Now the brain is firing incoherently and when it's firing incoherently we're incoherent at the same time
You're sitting in the zoom meeting and it's not t-rex
It's your co-worker and you're actually producing the same chemicals as if you're being chased by t-rex, but you don't you're not running
You're not fighting
You're not hiding
you're doing sitting there and those those chemicals are running through the body and the heart is actually pumping really hard because
It's turned on and it's got a run fight or hide and you're sitting there
And the heart is actually pumping against the closed system and the heart starts to become incoherent and when
Incoherence takes place in the heart the interference of waves actually causes energy to drop in the heart
So now you have no energy in the heart
You have no energy in the brain and now the person is living in their animal self in that animal nature, right?
And so they're waiting
For something to change in their outer world
They're waiting for something to change in their outer world to take away this feeling of fear or anxiety or
frustration or impatience or resentment or pain or suffering or guilt or shame and
They're living by that emotional state and they would rather cling
To those memories and those emotions because it's least it's the known right and it's survival
Why because in survival the unknown you better run from the unknown there's better chances of survival. So nobody takes a chance, right?
Okay, so so then back to the 3d world then
the Newtonian world the classical world of quantum physics is all about
Newtonian physics is all about the predictable, right?
And we can shoot a rocket to the moon if we know the distance and the speed of the rocket
We can determine the time it's gonna take to get there. So this three-dimensional reality is all about predictions, right? Okay
Well, you can get what you want, but you got to work really hard
And it's gonna take a lot of time and energy you can develop the skills to get it
Okay now so is there possibly another way to do it? I mean, okay, let's look at another way
Is there another way to actually?
Do it in a shorter amount of time to shorten the distance
Between the thought of what you want and the experience of having it between the cause and the effect from one point of consciousness
I'm here and another point of consciousness. I want the experience of this here
Is there a way to do that? Okay. Well, let's unpack the whole model of quantum physics
Okay, so you look at an atom an atom is ninety nine nine nine nine nine nine nine percent nothing and I say nothing
I mean, it's energy. It's nothing. It's a point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one percent
Physical and material and it is a site. Yeah, that's where we're made of and it's a scientific fact
It's the mathematics prove that we're perceiving less than one percent of reality
Okay
So what we're perceiving then is the frequency of light the wavelength of light coming off the Sun which is the rainbow
Bouncing off of objects that give us the illusion of separation in three-dimensional reality. Okay, that's that's what we're seeing
Right, we're seeing and experiencing the material world by light being being projected onto it
Take away the light out of three-dimensional reality
You don't really have a whole lot of experience of it. You bump into a lot of things. I mean take away all light
Okay, so so the the the atom is both particle
Material. Mm-hmm and wave and what's wave? What is wave frequency? What is frequency energy?
What is frequency and energy do they carry information?
Okay, so the quantum field then is that invisible field of energy a frequency that exists
Beyond our senses that we're not perceiving but it still exists just because we're unaware of it
Doesn't mean it doesn't exist. Okay, so how much of your waking day in your waking life?
Do you put your attention on matter and how much of your waking day do you put your attention on frequency and energy?
Well throw in the hormones of stress
And your attentions on your body on the environment and time where you place your attention is where you place your energy
So now all of your energy and attention is is
Invested in this three-dimensional reality and it appears really real because that's where our attention is
Believe in the thought I can't meditate or I don't have enough time or I'm a really important person
I got to me too many emails the answer. It's garbage day or it's my mother's fault. It's my ex's fault
I want to complain. I want to blame I want to make excuses. I want to lay down my bladders full
I like this. What am I doing wrong? They're agitated and patient
that's
that's the personality that has been hardwired and
Conditioned emotionally into the past that's resisting the unknown
It would rather cling to suffering and take a chance and possibilities. So our events we say, okay
here's the knowledge and I can say now with a
Great degree of certainty more than ever
That if you actually do this and you stretch yourself a little bit further
Than where you would normally go at home your brain will change and if you teach people how to do this
over and over again and no different
Than training an animal. Mm-hmm. The body is the animal. Are you training the body that you're in charge?
Is that what you're telling the body? It's no longer the mind that you're the mind. Yes, and when you do that
Those victories add up and all of a sudden there is a liberation of energy
There goes the guilt there goes the pain there goes the whatever it doesn't matter if it's health
It doesn't matter if it's wealth or success
It doesn't matter if it's a loving relationship a change in a career a mystical experience
Whatever it is the person all of a sudden starts to relax into the present moment
I think we're reality producing machines
I mean, there's no there's no single individual on this planet who doesn't create reality unless they have a brain injury or something
But for the most part most of us are engaged in reality, you know, and we do cause effects
I think we reach a certain point in our life where we stop learning and we start feeling and when we use feelings as a
barometer for the unknown
It's a it's it's contraindicated because feelings are usually a record of a past experience
So we try to predict how that future event is going to be based on a feeling and we always return back
To the old self again, so I
Love the idea of how we can actually produce effects
I love the idea that every human being is either lives in one of two states of mind. We either live in
creation which is growth and expansion and and it's some
Health and homeostasis the emotions of love and joy and trust make us feel connected to something bigger than us
Or we live in a state of
survival and the state of survival is living in stress and living in stress is when your body is knocked out of balance and
The redundancy of that cycle over time that imbalance that keeps happening begins to break the body down
and and I think the biggest problem for us because of the size of our brains is
We can turn on the stress response just by thought alone and we do it all day long in
that
continuous
redundant
Being out of balance over time that imbalance becomes the new balance and now we're headed for
contraction and disease and feeling separate from the field and being selfish instead of selfless we begin to
live in a state of breakdown in a state of
Disease and a lack of health and and so then those emotions then of those
Survival chemicals endorse the ego and then we become more self-indulgent and more self-important and more
self-serving
Because that's what those chemicals do so
We live in one of those two states of mind now those chemicals tend to be highly addictive
So this is really good dinner conversation. We can talk about it, right?
But actually breaking through that's I think
When you free yourself from the chains of those emotions that that that we memorize
When we actually break through and when we remove
That mind out of the body when we break the emotion that's trapped in physical flesh and the body's liberated
That's true self-love. That's true. Joy. It's the liberation of energy
So the anger that once was in there the hatred that was once into the prejudice that was once in there is transformed
It's transmuted into joy and it's the same energy, but it just has a different spin
And so no one can do that for you
You know that that isn't something where someone you know
waves a wand and then it happens you have to actually be willing to be uncomfortable as
You break that addiction and be okay with it
And then the moment the body's liberated and you feel that expansion
That's the natural state of being now you say I love myself so much because I went further than I thought I could go I
Transcended some limitation about myself in the way. I think in the way I act in the way I feel that's the personality
That's the identity
changing one of those things
Really changing and not just like changing your mind like I want vanilla ice cream instead of chocolate ice cream
But truly changing something that changes your
neurology or neurocircuitry
Changes the chemistry which is your emotions that signal the gene that begins to change your very
expression of health and a very expression of life
Talking about when you make that emphatic, you know declaration where you make that change
And it's undeniable
there's a
biological
Neurological and
Quantum effect as a result of it
Well, I think I flirt primarily with the idea of how subjective mind has an effect on the objective world
You know Newtonian physics is about cause and effect. It's about something outside of you
Fundamentally changing something inside of you, you know, we are an expression or a reflection of the environment
so
As long as the environment is influencing how we're thinking and feeling we can only be as great as the environment
So and if we're thinking and feeling equal to the environment, we could only create more of the same environment
you know the idea that we can change something inside of us in our in our consciousness in our thoughts and in our feelings and
be able to memorize both neurologically in our brain and
hardwire that information install hardware and
Condition the body emotionally to be a mind
So mind and body are working together if we're able to maintain that modified state of being then
There should be some evidence outside of us. So instead of cause and effect. I
always love the idea of causing effects and
to cause an effect so
The quantum model says you can cause an effect. And so I think where we get stuck with that is the idea that
You know that it has to be predictable that we should be able to
know how it's going to happen and that is that is I think our biggest error because we can never control the outcome of the
Unpredictable that's the quantum model. It has to be uncertain. It has to come in a way that we least expect that surprises us that
That leaves no doubt that what we did inside of us
Produced some effect outside of us and and when you begin to have those small
Synchronicities at first and then they turn into larger and larger events and you experience that
That on that wonder or that joy and appreciation for being alive
I think that's the natural state of being I think that's
Having that kind of sensibility coming from within us instead of needing something outside of us to change our state
What a sense then it's not the personality that chooses the body or the parents or it's the soul that chooses it
Does that make sense? But if a person gets caught in routine and gets lost in the quagmire of life
then the ego takes over and the soul is diminished and
now the person is doing their best to become a somebody a someone on something be somewhere in some time and of course if
That's the journey
And the person is not willing to find wisdom or look for truth
Then they can play on that level for as long as they want until they're tired of it
And when they finally get bored with it and they'll they'll want to choose something else and eternity is a long time. Wouldn't you agree?
So then the soul then says, okay, here's the options probable lines of time
there are probable lines of time that are the more probable than others and
There is a probable line of time for living in the same body and
Raising your frequency
To the point where you can go wherever you want with your body. That's the ultimate yes or no
and you can whip bread out of nothing and you can be in two places at once and you can be on the
An alternate universe and have a whole life there and you can be dimensional
That's that's the freedom of when you've mastered yourself and you've mastered the conditions
but most of us are
Headed in a certain timeline based on our genes and based on our own personal evolution
And that's what makes this time right now
so powerful
this time right now is the age of information and
in the age of information ignorance is actually a choice and
People are beginning to realize that I don't need a doctor to find out what my disease is
I don't need to go to the library or talk to my teacher
I can just I can just find the information and people are starting to wake up
to greater understandings and that is starting to become the collective and that
Collective energy in the field the collective consciousness the collective awareness is changing the future of humanity
Yes, or no and at the same time
The past is crumbling
There is economic collapse. There's political collapse. There's religious collapse. There's
environmental collapse there's there's
All of that is breaking down
Journalistic collapse and who watches the news and expects to hear the truth
I mean, it's just all falling apart and it's becoming so obvious
To people that all of a sudden they're realizing that the people that run the world or people that are in places of power
Are actually really really worse off than you and I and the only thing that has to happen
Is that we have to collectively become one mind?
And when we've collectively become one mind we no longer seduced by those things and
We are now like a flock of birds all moving in the same direction and those fish all of a sudden moving as a school
Nobody's leading everybody's leading
We're just connected and what do you think we're doing when you tune in to the power of love in this room?
Don't you know everybody dialing into that same frequency is causing that frequency to be in this room
And if everybody's doing it, it's getting more collimated more coherent more organized. And if you put your attention on it, there's more of it
So then when you're leading with your heart, that's enough
That's enough
So then when you have a collective mind
And people are moving in that way and they're no longer reacting to politics or whatever and they no longer need those things
You're catching somebody who's starting to awaken
Yes or no, and if you're focusing on the divine and that's where all of your attention is you won't see ethnicity
She won't see skin color. You won't see anything as separation. You'll just be like wow
Nice costume to the masquerade. I should have wore that
It's crazy because then people go get their genetics found out and you know some of them, you know
Just really have an intolerance to some culture and they're 40% of that culture
So
What makes this time for me so unique and I'm speaking
Personally is that there's such a quickening going on more things are happening in a shorter amount of time
Would you agree and if more things are happening in a shorter amount of time?
It becomes more difficult to predict the next moment
This point we're reaching this nodal point is the point of in
unpredictability and the old is collapsing and the collapsing of the old should never be faced with fear with
bigotry with with with anger with hostility with guilt sadness and shame because that's how we've been controlled all along and
By the way, I mean, I'm not a conspiracy theorist, but if you want to control people manipulate their emotions
So as we move closer and closer to that point the probability of us changing our life
the length of our life not from
Low stress foods and not from vitamins. All those things are good matter to matter
But stress is going to downregulate the gene
Consume the body's energy and now that's going to begin to signal the gene to produce the disease that the person has inherited in the
first place
Are you with me still?
so when you react to someone or something and you're living by the same emotional state you keep the same genes on the same genes
off and that's your genetic destiny and now the awakening of this even if
Even if we change little timelines just this week
We changed lines of time you change something about yourself you are going to walk into a different future
That is your genetic timeline and now you're bumped off course
You just got to be willing to stay in the unknown and be comfortable with it
And that's when you're at your greatest if people are not aware. How can they become aware and once they become aware
What sort of things should they start to do to start making those changes?
Yeah, thank you for for teasing that out. That's such a great question
you know, um
My interest is to give people the tools so that they have within their reach all the
Things they need to begin to apply and become scientists in their life
People don't know if you don't know that those stress hormones are addictive
Then you think they have power over you if you don't think that you can change your thought
Just because you have a thought it doesn't necessarily mean it's true
And the moment I realized that I was free, right?
And if you isolate yourself a lot and you don't you're not out in the world because of whatever
You'll you'll you'll you'll start to believe every thought that you think is the truth. And so that challenge then of saying, okay, I
Do truly want to be happy. I do truly want to be healthy
I do truly want to have a life that that is really empowering that I feel good about
okay, well, let's take a look like if no different than
Well, you use the example of Tiger Woods no different than Tiger Woods watching himself
Swing on a video observing himself play
No different than a person who stands in front of an audience and does a lecture and watches them
Do the lecture nobody else will see what they see
They'll see themselves very differently than anybody else and they'll they'll see themselves do it and they'll want to self-correct
They want to evolve their experience now because we got this big frontal lobe 40% of our entire brain. That's our conscience
That's a seed of our awareness. That's our creative center when we ask the question
What would it be like to be in a different life or to be happy if?
instead of getting on your cell phone or instead of getting on your social media or instead of turning on the TV or
Calling a friend and instead of doing something to distract you from that
Possible answer if you sat with it long enough and that creative center turned on
It would naturally
Scan the whole entire landscape of the brain because it's the CEO
It's the symphony leader as connections to all parts of the brain and it's gonna look out over the landscape of the brain and look
At the knowledge you've learned in the experiences that are stitched in your brain that are associated with what you know
To answer that question and as it calls up these different networks of neurons once the brain fires in tandem
You get an image or a picture in your mind and that's called intention. You see a new possibility, right? So then
This is why I am passionate about what we're doing
I never thought
Reagan that I would see the kind of changes in people's physical health that I've seen in the last two years now
People do the best with what they think is available
If you don't know that this is possible
You are going to make the same choice and that may be relying on some pharmaceutical something outside of you some therapy
Whatever. There's nothing wrong with that
But if your response it hasn't changed in your life
The efficacy of whatever you're doing is going to be diminished
Okay, so once I now know that people could heal from different health conditions and there's evidence in the science and there's evidence in
Testimony like the person that you just recited
That's one of many many people that have had that experience when they stand on the stage at our week-long retreats and we call them
up
Why do I call them up on the stage because they are speaking the truth?
They are the example of truth and I want people to become aware of that possibility
Why because if you're unaware of it, it doesn't exist for you
Consciousness is awareness, right? And so then with consciousness you can have consciousness without energy
So there that that thought of another possibility is a different energy
It's a different possibility and and so now once you know, it's possible then
Okay. Now let's get down
To stepping in the footprints that other people have left behind
Why if you're telling the story of your past every single day and 50% of that isn't even the truth
Then you're reliving a miserable life
You never even had all for the reason to excuse yourself from change
Stop telling the story of your past and start telling the story of your future
Stop romancing your past and start romancing your future
Why not fall in love with your future as much as you fall in love with your past?
How many people in this audience?
Actually believe in the idea
That the way you think has some effect on your life. That's your thoughts create your life
You believe that yes?
So how many people here actually woke up this morning and consciously created a future
You
Know the biggest reason why people don't do it is
Because you don't really believe it's true
You see if you knew on a gut level that it was absolutely true
Would you ever miss a day?
Come on, and would you ever let any thought slip by your awareness that you didn't want to experience?
So
Your brain according to neuroscience is organized to reflect
Everything you know in your life
Your brain is a record of your environment. It's a record an artifact of your past
So if you believe this then then does your environment control your thinking?
Or does your thinking control your environment?
So if you wake up in the morning
And you get out of bed on the same exact side as you did the day before
You shut the alarm clock off with the same finger you slip into your favorite slippers
You shuffle into the bathroom, and you use the toilet like you always do
Then you walk over to the mirror, and you look at yourself to remember who you are
Then you get into the shower, and you wash yourself in the same routine way
Then you groom yourself to look like everybody expects you to look
Then you go downstairs, and you drink coffee out of your favorite mug
Then you drive the work the same way as you did the day before
You see the same people that push the same emotional buttons
You do the exact thing that you know how to do and you memorize and can do so well that you're an expert at
Then you hurry up and rush home, so you can hurry up and check your emails
So you could hurry up and go to bed, so you can hurry up and do it all over again
Now here's my question. Did your brain change at all that day?
We could say that you were thinking the same thoughts
Performing the same actions that create the same experiences that produce the same emotions
But secretly expecting something to change in your life. Would you agree?
so then as
The environment turns on different circuits in your brain you begin to think equal to your environment as
You see the same people and go to the same places and do the same things at the same time
It's the external environment. That's turning on different circuits in your brain causing you to think equal to everything that you know and
As long as you think equal to everything that's familiar and known to you. What do you keep creating more of?
Same life now the quantum law is still applying to you
You're just thinking equal to everything that you know and you keep creating more of the same
to change
To truly change is to think greater than your environment and every great person in history knew this
Whether it was William Wallace or Mahatma Gandhi or Martin Luther King or Queen Elizabeth the first or Joan of Arc they all had a vision
They all had an idea couldn't see it couldn't smell it couldn't taste it couldn't feel it, but it was alive in their mind
It was so alive in their mind that they began to live as if that reality was actually happening now
So, can you believe in a future that you can't see or experience with your senses yet?
But you've thought about enough times in your mind that your brain is literally changed to look like the event has already happened
Neuroscience says it's absolutely possible. You got to go out into life and try it out. Okay, I've changed my internal state
You could have a great meditation and connect your heart could open to me. You could open your heart
You'd be amazing. You feel like a day is invincible and you get up and then the rest of your day
You're unconscious of the 15 hours of your day. So you're gonna weigh one hour of
Being in a different state of being against 15 hours of you being unhappy and rushing and in a program. So then
How many times?
Do we have to forget?
Until we stop forgetting and start remembering that's called change. How many times do we have to go unconscious?
To the point where we no longer go unconscious and we stay conscious
That's the moment of change now if you're truly out of the bleachers and you're on the playing field
And this happens to a lot of people in our work. They say, you know, I really believe that this is the truth
I really believe that you could heal yourself. I really believe you could change your life. I've seen the testimonials. I
Just never believe that it could happen to me. Now. This is a big moment. Now. You're really stepping on the playing field. So
The person who starts doing their work, they're not they're not interested in healing the true the person who's truly
Interested in this work. They understand that the only way they can heal is that they have to change
They're not saying I'm gonna wait for my wealth or my healing to happen in order for me to feel grateful and be
Joyful in life. They're saying if I feel grateful my healings gonna begin
Right, and if I if I'm feel more whole then there should be some change in my gene expression
So they've studied the content. They've studied the information and now it becomes extremely practical
So they may have a great meditation and we've seen this happen to many people
They sleep better. They have less pain. They have more energy, but their blood values never change now. They don't say oh, I
Feel better, but I'm failing this doesn't work. They say what is it about me?
That's stopping this from completely healing. Okay. How am I?
In my waking day the moment you begin to ask that question
You turn on the frontal lobe and the frontal lobe is the seat of your conscience
Now the moment you start looking at at the end of your day. How did I do? This is such an important question
How'd I do today? Did I fall from grace? When did I lose it? And who did I lose it with? I had another opportunity
How would I do it differently they'll tell you I've seen them stand on the stage and tell their story and say I
Had to start really watching myself in my life
Yeah, how I was emotionally responding to my ex how I was emotionally responding to my financial problems
I had to really really pay attention that and that takes an
Enormous amount of energy and an enormous amount of awareness. Yeah to stop the program, right?
So you forget and you go Sam I went unconscious that now you didn't lose you didn't fail
You just became conscious now if you keep becoming so conscious of your unconscious states, you're you're outside the program
You're only in the program when you're unconscious
The moment you're conscious you can objectify your subjective self so you can see yourself through the eyes of someone else
So the learning process
Comes from the mistake the brain learns by mistakes and surprises
I've made enough of them in my life. It's just whether you're gonna do it again. Yeah, you want to do it again
You're back in the habit back in the routine if you say
This is it the next time that happens. I am NOT gonna do that not for anybody else
but because those emotions
Actually, my response to that person or that circumstance is actually weakening the organism is that person that circumstance worth it?
so then
It's evolution it's evolution the challenge then has to be met with a greater level of mind now if you're just doing your meditation
Just because you want to please God or do the right thing or feel good about yourself
that's gonna get stale after a while because it's just gonna become another routine between your coffee and your shower and your emails and your
Drive to work and people aren't present, right? So so
the familiar past conditioning is based on the past that thought and the feeling but
Habituation is the programming them to predictable future. That's the known
So if you teach a person how to find the present moment
That's where the unknown exists and that takes that takes a lot of energy a lot of awareness and yet if you practice it
The body literally will begin to respond to the mind. It's like training an animal
It finally relaxes and when that occurs your response to people and circumstances in your life will be different because
You overcame yourself at the beginning of the day, I believe that your personality creates your personal reality and
In order to change your personal reality your life
It means then that on some level we have to change because nothing changes in our life unless we change
so if people have
Understand that 90% of the thoughts that they think every day are the same thoughts as the day before
It that's that's a fact and the same thoughts always lead to the same choices the same choices always lead to the same
Behaviors the same behaviors create the same experiences and the same experiences produce the very same feelings and emotions
And those same emotions influence our very same thoughts and our biology or in our circuitry or in our chemistry or hormones or gene
Expressions stays the same
Because we're the same
But the repetition of firing and wiring the same circuits in our brain in the same way
Causes us to
Create a very finite set of circuitry that becomes our identity and our personality and nerve cells that fire together wire together
Which means you keep doing it. It gets easier for them to fire and they run more automatically
So turns out 95% of who we are by our midlife is a set of memorized
Behaviors unconscious habits hardwired thoughts and attitudes
Conditioned emotions that are so familiar to us that it doesn't even feel like
Fear or it doesn't feel like sadness. It's just who we are
so it usually takes crisis or trauma or disease or diagnosis of your lowest point in your life where you're not to your knees and
for that moment
You actually have a view of yourself outside of yourself you can see yourself
from a different state that the facade the the the
The whole illusion is over and that's when a person really begins to think about what they've been thinking about
They begin to notice how they speak or how they act and I think they begin to pay attention to those feelings
on a more
Regular and conscious basis and the word meditation I look this up because when I started my journey, I'm
very
Scientifically minded the word meditation the symbol means to become familiar with
so
So then the first step to change if you wanted to create a new life you have to change
It to change your personal reality you have to change your personality and the first step is consciousness or becoming aware
So the moment you become conscious of your unconscious thoughts the moment you become aware of your automatic reflexive habits
And and your emotional reactions the moment you can become so conscious of those unconscious states of mind and body
That you don't go unconscious again
So familiar with those states and how many times do we have to forget or go?
Unconscious till we no longer forget or go unconscious and we stay conscious
That's that's that's it that's lighting a match in a dark place and most people when they do meditation
They they actually think when those voices come up and when the chatter starts and those emotions start
they actually think that they're doing their meditation wrong and
I want them to know that they're actually doing it
Right because you're coming up against those thoughts that slip by your awareness unnoticed or unchecked by many people
You all of a sudden catch how you speak and
People say if I really want to be happy, let's think about this. I
Don't wanna I don't want to complain. I don't want to blame. I don't want to make excuses
I don't want to feel sorry for myself. I'm gonna stop that now that's breaking a habit of being yourself
that's a that takes a lot of energy and a lot of awareness and and and our environment then the
Circumstances our environment are always available for us to think and feel equal to everything in our life, you know
So the environment for many people as we said earlier controls the way they think and feel
so when they respond to their co-worker when they respond to the news when they respond to the
the the traffic in their life
That response causes them to return back to those unconscious programs
so but sitting in a meditation and really sitting in the fire and
Believing that there's something on the other side of that thought
Believing that there's something on the other side of some behavior or some emotion that feel it makes us feel a certain way
that's that's stepping into the unknown and and it takes
It takes us disconnecting from the environment. That's what meditation is about playing music or hearing nothing
Closing your eyes and not eating not smelling not tasting that feeling with your body
You're putting your body away and you're not letting it be the mind or the program. You're making it sit
Still you're training the animal right and and a person starts feeling emotional and they catch themselves
Starting to feel those emotions instead of letting that emotion drive certain thoughts or actions
that person settles the body down in the meditation and
Brings it back into the present moment and that's a victory if you study the neuroscience of culture, you know, it's so so unique because
We have we share the same biology
We share the same brain and because we share the same biology in the same brain
We we have certain universal traits that are that are unique to human beings. We smile when we're happy
We frown and we're sad we sleep at night for the most part. We grab a stick well with an opposing thumb
So structure and function are highly related and those are universal traits and then we have our
Individual traits and that's kind of like how the brain is wired right? That's like our fingerprint as opposed to our hand, right? So
We have an individual series of traits and that make us unique and we have our universal traits
but what bridges the universality of us commonalities human beings with our individuality and that's culture and
Culture really is defined for the most part by the past
what has worked over generations or
traditions that have sustained the culture based on one thing and
That one thing is an environment
so a culture in northern Mongolia is certainly different than a culture in central Mexico Mexico because
It's a different environment and those different customs that are created from that environment allow that culture to sustain itself
So look at look at great people in history that that changed the culture whether it was Gandhi whether it was William Wallace
Whether it was Joan of Arc whether it was Martin Luther King, whoever it was that changed the culture
What they did really well as they showed people that there was an alternative future that they could actually
Believe or perceive in their mind now
You can't see that future if you're living by the same emotions of the past
And for most people they live by the emotions of the past
What you have to do is you got to get people out of their resting state. They have to become inspired
They have to become enthusiastic and theos filled with God they have to become
Motivated in some way they have to be moved
And when they are moved emotionally then that that that energy that emotion
Causes them to see the same future as that leader sees and you when you get people
Seeing that same future and they have that clear intention and you combine that with a different emotion
You're changing people's state of being now
Get enough people doing that and what he what happens is you get an emergent consciousness
emergence in biology is such a phenomenal thing because when you see a group of
Birds or flock of birds flying in the same direction or a school of fish moving together
They appear as a larger organism when you study that principle in biology
You think that there's a leader that everybody's following that it's a top-down phenomenon in fact
It's not it's a bottom-up phenomenon and everybody's leaving leading everybody's
Behaving in the same way and the appearance of a larger organism becomes more sustainable for that species. So
We have such a stigma in our minds that if you lead with too much passion, you're gonna get it in the end whether
your Jesus Christ or Abraham Lincoln or
William Wallace, whoever it was
The outcome for truth is usually you lose your life
But the real question is what if everybody's leading?
You just can't take out everybody now. So so this is a really
Important time because the emergent consciousness that has to take place
Has to be built on principles and the principles that people can actually wrap their mind around
They have to keep their mind on it for a period of time where they're not distracted by
Technology, they're not distracted by tick-tock and they're not distracted by social media and they're not distracted by the news that that that that the the
eminent
Condition of the world right now in the way things are going based on self-interests
Are all based on survival and you can control people
When you control their emotions and when you control their emotions you control their attention and if you can capture a person's attention
You can capture their energy because where you place your attention is where you place your energy
And so you could actually program people to do anything
Based on the emotion that they feel and fear is a great emotion
To cause people to rely on some authoritative figure to lead them away. So
If there's a new consciousness that emerges that that is based on
not fruits and nuts and not
You know not on crystals not on colonics
Not on any of those things, but this is game time
This is where something else has to be born in human beings that is already innate in us
And that is the power to organize as a species
When we begin to heal one another when we begin to inform one another and begin to respect one another when we begin to
shine from one another when we begin to stand up for one another one begin to
abilities and then damage
To people that there are other ways of doing thing and share that right information
I think an emergent consciousness will actually take place and
God, I think this is the time in history more than ever
Where where it matters the most when people
First thing they have to do is they have to overcome their survival states. They have to overcome their programs
I gotta be willing to sit with themselves long enough to wonder what's on the other side of I can't or it's too hard
Or I want to give up or this sucks. What's on the other side of those thoughts? Those are just programmed thoughts
What's on the other side of this emotion called guilt or this emotion called frustration? What's on the other side of it?
Right, so you have people to a certain point to give them a little bit of help
But the key then is we've done we've done studies on this if you close your eyes and you place your attention on your heart
It turns out where you place your attention is where you place your energy, right?
so if you can put your attention on your heart and not your cell phone and
You can keep it on your heart and feel it and experience it and pay attention to it by paying attention to your heart
You're actually giving it your energy now your heart tends to feel different emotions
Than other parts of your body and what emotions it loves to feel is love
Compassion care kindness gratitude inspiration freedom. These are elevated emotions
So if you could put your attention on your heart
We see from the technology that we built in time and not a very long amount of time just a few minutes
You'll start to see this very low frequency of the heart start going up
Which means the the energy that's indigenous to the heart, but the heart uses only you're actually feeding it
It's at energy
So if you do that then and then you can slow your breathing down when you slow your breathing down
You slow your brain waves down. We've measured that thousands of times. So instead of
The short breath or this instead of this kind of shallow breath
You really work on taking long slow breaths through your heart
Inhale with the intention of relaxing hold it with the intention of relaxing while you hold it
Exhale with the intention of relaxing blow all the air out hold it for a few seconds. You're not gonna die
Relax again inhale again and just do a series of three or four or five or six of these depending on
Working with your body so that it starts to feel safe again. That's what it is
It's slow your brain waves down. You slow your breathing down. You slow your breathing down you convert from the sympathetic
To the parasympathetic and that's what we see then all of a sudden we see the person's parasympathetic
Nervous doesn't go up and the sympathetic goes down. What does that mean?
There I'm moving out of stress. Okay, the body's moving into that state of growth and repair now put your attention on your heart
Now do something really cool
Amplify that's the amplifier. That's the creative sensor. So what do you want to feel like?
What emotion do you want to feel when a future experience happens? Whatever that is?
Feel the gratitude feel the joy feel the freedom and breathe and feel and feel and breathe and keep
Relaxing into your heart keeping your attention nowhere else out of the millions of things you can put your attention on
That's your target and you work with your body and you're breathing you feel it as you start
Relaxing into your heart you keep working on relaxing into your heart and you feel it you feel that emotion
They'll come a moment where that energy will naturally start moving up to the brain and when that happens
The survival centers shut down brain moves into alpha you see more in pictures and images
You could take it's like a taking a sheet of paper a sheet on a bed and going like this
The heart sends is propagating wave right into the brain
Just follows boom right after the stroke volume and it's telling the brain to be creative to dream to be you know to be unlimited
So the more you do that, here's the key
The more you do it the more it becomes a skill now
When a person has a panic attack, right? What they do is they mismanage their attention
They they picture the worst scenario that could possibly take place and then they say no. What if this happens?
Oh, what if this happened? What if this episode they're making it actually ten times worse because if you prepare for the worst
There's always better chances of survival
the problem is they're combining that image in their mind and they're actually living the experience emotionally and
so they're taking that thought and
That feeling that image and that emotion that stimulus and response and they're conditioning the body subconsciously to become the mind of fear
After a certain point when the body's that out of balance
It will have a panic attack try as you may to control it with your conscious
Can you program that subconsciously and then it gets worse because after that one you can't anticipate when the next one's gonna happen
So you start getting ready for the next one and that's what exactly starts the cycle
Okay
So what we discovered that the more you relax into your heart and feel these elevated emotions
It's exactly like a panic attack only it's a love attack
We have such great evidence to show that there's something very profound
that happens
when a person has a transcendental moment and they have an
Interaction with energy when they hit those elegant states
They sometimes come to events as sick
We draw their blood at the beginning of the event their event and they we see there what happens to their brain
We see what happens to their heart and we know this person has had a profound moment and we draw their blood and we measure
everything afterwards
if we take the plasma of those individuals as an example and we take a
Pseudovirus that looks just like SARS kov-2
Or we actually take now recently
We actually did the actual SARS virus and we put that virus in
The presence of that person that advanced meditator that had that transcendental moment
There is a consistent resistance to the virus the virus
Cannot enter the cell of that person in
People that are novice meditators and they come to a week-long event
Some of the virus enters their cell and some of the virus stays out
So there's somewhat of an immunity and all the controls they get infected
Alright, so we know now that there's some agent some cofactor in the blood when a person has this moment
So we've gone through some extensive scientific studies and we actually isolated the very protein
that stops the virus from entering the cell and if we take that protein and
We put it in the infected plasma of the controls
All of the infected controls become uninfected
Now we're not getting that from anywhere out there. We're actually finding it in someone
Who has had a moment where they've interacted with oneness with wholeness and whether it's there's some
Change in energy in the blood and there are some proteins being released, but we're starting to discover
There's some powerful agents when this occurs take the blood of that advanced meditator and put it
Take their plasma and put it in a uterine cancer cell and and the cancer cells the mitochondria
The powerhouses of the cells are switched on and they're pumping out a lot of energy
That's why they're almost immortal if we take the blood of the advanced meditator and we subject to a uterine cancer cell
75% of the energy comes out of the mitochondria takes the wind out of the cells
take the plasma of that at the same advanced meditator and
put it on a neuron that has Alzheimer's and produces the amyloid protein and there's a
Significant change in the gene expression of the Alzheimer gene
Take that person then and subject their blood to the variance
the lambda variant the Delta variant the beta variant and
The same thing occurs they're resistant
To the virus now, what does that mean? Okay
If you really think about this
It would suggest that there's very dramatic
Environmental changes taking place from a scientific standpoint
Anybody who sees this kind of gene expression change or change in biology?
They would say oh my god that suggests that there's a dramatic change in the environment
The problem is is the person is sitting in a ballroom in a hotel
There's not a lot a lot of things going on in a ballroom in a hotel. It's not a changing environment
Where is all that change coming from?
information from the field
so we have
great
great testimony in our community of people that have reversed all kinds of things and people have created all kinds of wealth and
created all kinds of mystical moments and
We have really great evidence in our scientific studies and evidence is the loudest voice
It is the voice that makes the biggest difference
so
What kind of human being then?
Who has trained themselves?
To no longer be victim to their environment if I said to you Emilio
Why what's up with you today? And you say I'm sad because of this person or this circumstance
I would say oh we mean that person or that circumstance is controlling the way you feel in the way you think
Well anything that's controlling the way you feel in the way you think you're victim to
So then when things are good, you feel good when things are bad you feel bad, right? And if you feel bad
Then you look for something out there to make this feeling go away
But then when the fun the novelty or the event is over here comes that feeling again
And you got to go chase something else. Well
The
Response from many people to their environment is actually weakening their body the stress response
They react to some event and their reaction to the event is actually weakening the organism now short-term
It's cool all organisms can handle that but the long-term effects of that just diminishes or taps the body's
Resources of vital energy. There's no energy to heal. There's no energy for growth and repair
So what we're suggesting
Is that when the person becomes less victim to their environment and
realizing that they're more of the creator of their environment and they're less the
response to the environment weakens them less
Because they know how to self-regulate and change
they'll be less susceptible to things in their environment large or small and
Creating a life
That is meaningful for a person
Someone as young as you and you start seeing that you're actually creating it
You every time you get feedback a breadcrumb from the universe saying Emilio keep going
Keep your keep your head down keep going you're running gonna run into something big
All of those things are convincing you that you are not
The victim to your life that you're actually the creator of your life and people who actually do this
It's not that you react. The question is how long you react
and teaching people how to move out of those states and
Back into homeostasis back into balance by self-regulating with their eyes open
Getting so good at doing it in their meditation with their eyes closed that they could actually do it with their eyes open
In their life now, it's a different game. So
Get enough people
In the world
Becoming less reactive to their environment
They're less controlled by their environment and the side effect of that is there's a huge change in our biology
huge I can I could say right now with
Certainty I can say that if people commit
To say as an example seven days of an event that we do I can say there will be
So many biological changes that take place in their body. We have the evidence that says that
But we have such a profound hope
For humanity in what we're discovering when the brain and the heart are coherent my goodness
There's a feeling where you can call it the zone or whatever you want to call it
We're just you feel like you have enough time
To get things done and no person no circumstance is gonna break you from your state
Right that that that zone or whatever you want to call that is actually teachable. So do you have to reach gamma to do that?
No, we're just knowing that the people that hit gamma they had an instantaneous biological upgrade. There's the eczema
37 years of eczema the next day it's gone back to your original question
we have great evidence in testimony and
We have great evidence in our scientific studies and evidence is the loudest voice and you can't tell me you're too old to do
This you can't tell me you're too sick to do this. I've seen people with 50 brain tumors
That were emaciated couldn't walk couldn't speak on the stage talking in front of a naughty can't tell me you're too sick to do this now
If you examine that person, you know who comes to the event and there's no hope, you know
they you have three months to live you have six months to live and
They're not accepting that or believing that or surrendering to that. They're actually saying there's got to be some other way
There's got to be some other way if I created this is it possible that I that I can uncreate it
So the person who's was on the stage telling that story and and and it may have taken them
18 months
But they never missed a day
Why is that essential because there were days where they felt so bad in their body?
So sick that they didn't feel like doing their meditation, but they did it
There were days they had so much doubt
Because their condition was actually worsening and they could have succumbed to their doubt, but they they did their meditation
Anyway, there were days
that they were in such an incredible fear because the doctor told them it was three months and it would be over and it was
The three month period and they had every reason to not do their meditation. They did it
Anyway, they could have said I don't have enough time. I have kids I got schedules
They found time to do it and it was the overcoming
the overcoming
The overcoming that was the becoming process overcoming becoming and and when they became that person
What is the side effect of your own personal transformation? For example, most people they when they have a physical health condition
The moment they notice there's a change like in pain in
Something in their sleep, you know, whatever it is, there's some change
They they make the connection right away. And that's when's the dog on the bone now
they're they're doing it twice a day not because they have to because that's their medicine and and I have sat with the
The scientists that have come to our events
I asked them to participate in a week-long event and the one guy who's looking at the virus outside the cell I said to him one
Well, how does this gonna change
How is this gonna change the way you do research?
He said this is this is my medicine this I see I've seen what it doesn't people say
Oh, are you saying meditation actually can cause your body be too resistant to viruses? No, no, no
No, I'm not saying that the date is saying that I'm not that's just this is not what I'm saying
the date is actually saying that so
What a great time in history to be alive because you could be young we have people that are eight years old nine years old
We have usually about between 70 and a hundred kids
That come to our event that are under the age of 25 and under we have kids that are seven eight nine years old that
Participate all the way. I got down on my knees with one of those one of these kids and we were that we were doing a
Specific meditation and I leaned over and I said so how is that?
He said that felt really good
And why do I want that to be a normal feeling for him because I want to know who he's gonna be
Yeah, we're changing his you're changing his gene expression at that age, right? And so so so
It's an amazing time. This is a time in history where it's not enough to know
There's a time in history to know how so my interest to answer your question is to demystify the process
No different than learning how to hit a golf ball
Everybody
That's has a skill that can do anything really well has done the exact same thing that I'm talking about
There's nothing different about it living in stress is living in survival and survival is a very
Primitive net mechanism that allows us to really really adapt to an environment that's threatening or dangerous
the moment you perceive a danger or threat you switch on an
Autonomic function in your body the sympathetic nervous system and there's an arousal
the arousal of those hormones
causes a heightening of the senses because now we want to become more acute that there's a danger there if there's a if there's a
Tiger in the bushes and you hear something rumbling around and it's night
You're gonna either run fight or freeze or high that's your choices
And so that works really well in survival for the short term because the arousal causes us feeling like we're more our body
We get a rush of energy the arousal causes our brain waves to change and to move into a more alert state
We now are our focus on what it is in the environment. We're giving it our attention all of our attention and
Now we're trying to predict what's going to happen in the future
Based on what we've known in the past or overlaying a known
Into the future so that we can prepare and normally when we don't know what it is
The unknown causes us to feel these primitive emotions of survival and it's best to run
It's best to fear the unknown. So
the challenge becomes
That that works really well for the short term
But when you switch on this
System and you're mobilizing enormous amounts of the body's energy and resources for some thread in your outer world
There's no energy in your inner world for growth and repair
There's no energy for long-term building projects and we start tapping the body's vital resources and that's what creates
Mental health or physical health or spiritual disease, right?
So because no organism can live in that emergency state for that extended period of time
it's like
There's a hurricane coming through Australia. You're not gonna be thinking about remodeling your kitchen at the at that time
It's not a time for long-term projects, right?
So now when we're in stress and we're in survival the self is the most important you don't trust
It's not a time to love. It's not a time to learn. It's not a time to communicate
It's not a time to be vulnerable. It's not a time to open your heart
It's not the time to sit down and close your eyes and go within you would be eating
The survival gene is switched on
And people spend 70% of their time living in the state
So then in that state where the arousal takes place
The brain moves into a heightened brainwave pattern called beta brainwave pattern now as I said
That's like driving your sports car in first gear on the freeway you it's it's the jumpstart
But you can't do it for a long period of time because in stress
Stress is signaled by the loss of control
Not being able to predict the next moment the unknown or the perception that something's gonna get worse and when you're in that state
You start trying to control and predict everything in your life
And you shift your attention from one person to another person to another problem to another thing to another place to another object
To a group of situations and every one of those elements has a neurological network in the brain. So the arousal
Causes the brain like a lightning storm in the clouds to start firing out of order
It starts firing incoherently and when the brain is incoherent, we're in coherent when the brain isn't working, right?
We're not working right. So then now the person is aroused in that state. It's never occurred to them that they could change that
In fact, they're telling you I am this way because of my boss because of my ex because of my past
Because of the news because of the global situation, whatever it is
And what they're really saying is I'm using something in my outer environment
To validate or justify why I feel this way
So then that means then they're also gonna be dependent on something in their outer environment to make them feel better
whether it's a drug or a
treatment or
Whatever it is
Complaining whatever it is that makes them feel better in the moment
They notice that they've done something and they've used something outside of them to make that feeling go away
They'll pay attention to what it was and every time they feel that feeling they'll become dependent on it
So now they're more dependent on their environments
So then the subconscious program is when things are good you feel good, but when things are bad you feel bad
So you're completely victim to your environment and the environment is actually
controlling the way you feel and think
Now anything that controls the way you feel and think you're victim to so I say Glenn. Why are you in such a bad mood?
I'm in the bad mood because of this person the circumstances the situation in my life
What you're really saying is something in my outer environment is literally controlling my feelings my emotions and my thoughts
So then it turns out
That when the person is in that state and they're in that aroused state their heart is beating because the sympathetic nervous system switched on
But they're not running. They're not fighting. They're not hiding
They're stepping on the gas pedal and they're stepping on the brake and the heart starts beating very incoherently and
Incoherent waves in the brain and incoherent waves in the heart
Diminish energy. So energy goes out of the brain energy goes out of the heart. We stopped thinking clearly we stopped rationalizing very well
We can't plan for the future
We're uninspired in our heart. We don't trust we can't feel gratitude. We can't feel appreciation. We can't feel love
It's not a time to feel any of those things. So then that's the beginning of disease, right?
So the person starts thinking about their problems and they turn on that stress response just by thought alone
And if the hormones of stress push the genetic buttons that create disease, then your thoughts are going to make you sick
Okay, and the question is if your thoughts can make you sick
Is it possible that your thoughts can make you well?
And by the same means if you're using every person every circumstance in your life to reaffirm
That dependency on that rush of emotions and you become addicted to the life. You don't even like
That's why change is so hard because you'd rather suffer and be in pain
Then take a chance in the unknown because the unknown you can't predict it
So people cling to the familiar and cling to the known and and so they become dependent on the environment
So what we found out was is there a way to make the brain more coherent?
Is there a formula that we can teach people instead of narrowing their focus on the material world
Narrowing their focus on everything known
What if they broaden their focus and they put it on nothing on space if they broaden their focus and they they they open their awareness
In this way what happens to the brain and we found the brain gets really organized
What if they traded fear for an elevated emotion and we taught them how to start working with their body?
First of all, you know mothering is the right as I said is the hardest job in the world in
There's I raised three kids three children and I practiced
Raising them within many of these principles and it was children
Number one thing is they have mirror neurons and mirror neurons are called empathy neurons
They model behavior when a lioness is teaching her cubs how to
Hunt she's not on a chalkboard and saying you go here you go there. She's saying watch me do this and
when the Cubs watch the lioness hunt as
They're looking at their mom hunting
They're priming the very circuits in their brain to hunt as they as they watch their mom
They're becoming their mom hunting and
The the the mother's act is selecting and instructing circuitry in their brain
equal to the environment that they're perceiving so
What does that mean to an adult or a human being?
You got to be the example of everything you want your children to be that's that's the fast path
To enlightenment so you can't tell your kids get off your technology
While you're over there on the computer or on the phone or on the TV and
Expect them to find something to do if you're not engaging
It's important to have technology, but it's also important to not have technology and and that's healthy as well
so one of the cool things that's happened in our
community is
we have
Hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of kids that come to our week-long events
from the age of seven or six all the way up to you know,
25 and 26 and sometimes there's 200 on the stage and the children are interested in
Understanding that they can create a better life. And so
There's certain principles. I think that really help parents and
Of course another one is never try to reason
With your children when they're emotional
Because we don't want to be reasoned with when we're emotional we want to be left alone until we get through the emotion
Because no information could actually enter their brain. That is an equal to that emotional state now
one of the most important things that I think you can teach a child by demonstration as
as well as
Story allegory and conversation is to teach them how to
shorten the refractory period of their emotional responses
So as I said you react to or respond to something or some condition in your outer world
That changes your emotional state. It could create fear could create anger create jealousy hostility envy, whatever
So
Then the lingering of that emotion that chemical if you allow it to last for
days to weeks
It's called the mood if it lasts for weeks and weeks
Two months on end that's called a temperament. Oh, he's an angry temperament. Why are you angry?
I'm angry because of this experience if you keep the same emotion going on
For years on end that's called the personality personality trait
so personality traits many times are created by the experiences and the emotions that
That don't keep us connected to the past
teaching children how to shorten their emotional reactions is
Such such so vitally important because when we're in that emotional state
There's a gap between the way things appear and the way things really are
we're altered grown on ourselves and
If we act during that time if we send an email during that time if we speak during that time
even if we think during that time
And we follow through will normally say I should have never said that I never should have never thought that I never
Sent that email. I should never done it
so
Children then are so neuroplastic. It's so important for you to have conversations with them
About how hard it is to overcome our emotional states when we're in the emotional state as an example my with my daughter
my kids
Whenever I saw her react to someone or something
Whatever I was doing as long as there was no injury or there's no one was in danger
I would stop and I turn around and I would observe her just for a minute
While she was doing what she was reacting to and she became aware that I was observing her
After she became aware that I was observing her then I would deal with it. However, I had to deal with it
At the end of the day I would lay down with my children in bed and I would start to talk about myself
God, I had a pretty tough day today. I
Lost it right around three o'clock. I couldn't get back the entire day
I was frustrated and I was impatient had too many things going on
I was overwhelmed and I wasn't present with you guys at dinner. I
Don't know making something up
You just pause for a moment
My daughter would say yeah, I got really angry at Paris today and I'd say I know I
Saw you
And I think she'd say yeah, she started telling me what happened I'd say
Okay
Now that you know what happened if it happened again
How would you do it differently? How would you behave differently?
How would you evolve your experience and then we would talk about it and between her and I we would come up with another plan
another
Rehearsal we would begin to okay. Let's let's okay
So Paris comes in just and you do this and said and so you're before you go to bed at night
Your subconscious mind is wide open to information
and so I would rehearse it with her before she would go to sleep well, you know while that
everybody was in bed and I would then tell a story of these kids that lived in a faraway land and
Then I would bring in each kids little
Allegory about them and what they were working on changing to to give them an opportunity that they could evolve their experience
Because you made it this far in a video I
Want to celebrate you most people start and don't finish most people never actually follow through most people say they want something
But they don't ever do the work to actually get it, but you're different you are special believe nation
You made it here all the way to the end and I love you
So it's a special celebration if you put a hashtag believe down in the comments below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you somewhere on the screen in a future video
Because you are awesome for three hours of pure Joe Dispenza inspiration check the video right there next to me
I think you'll love it continue to believe and I'll see you there and
Instead of getting up and getting on your cell phone and getting distracted
Sit with your triple filtered water or a glass of wine or whatever you're into the question without being distracted the contemplation
Process is the building process neurologically